>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Next is Jessie Daniels, Professor
of Sociology at Hunter College.
She studies race and
digital media technologies.
And she is going to share a story
about how some library
collections can be manipulated
by hate groups online
with her presentation
"Extremists in the Archive."
Jessie.
>> Jessie Daniels: Thanks,
it's great to be here.
I'm here today to talk to you
about extremists in the archive.
And part of what my research
has led me to believe is
that you can't understand the
world in which we live today
without understanding
white supremacy.
And by that I mean, both the system
of ideas that sets white people
above all others and
also the extremist groups
that I've encountered in some
of my research in the archive.
The first thing that I want to
share with you is this slide.
This is from an extremist
website that I found
that was called American
civil rights review.
And I actually came upon it
because it was discovered
by a college student
of mine where I taught
in suburban Long Island at the time.
This was in 2008.
And part of what this
website was arguing
through white supremacists lens
was that slavery was not that bad.
And they were using Library
of Congress materials,
a digital archive of the WPA project
that interviewed formerly enslaved
people, to make that argument.
So I want to talk about some
of the unintended consequences
of digitizing archives.
And I want to tell the story
of how I discovered this
website and how we got to here.
So I want to tell you a
little bit about my research.
In the '90s, I started --
actually in the late '80s,
but I started publishing in
1997 some research I had done
on a physical printed
archive of newsletters
from six different extremist
organizations, including the KKK
and actually David
Duke's organization,
a bunch of different ones.
And to do this research --
this was my dissertation
and then became my first book.
To do this research,
I had to travel.
I drove seven hours from where
I was in school at Austin,
Texas, to Montgomery, Alabama.
Where the Southern Poverty Law
Center keeps what they call a clan
watch archive.
They keep a trove of
these printed newsletters
of these extremist groups.
And I drove there and stood over a
copy machine for three or four days.
And through their generosity,
developed my archive
for the first publication.
In that research what I argued was
that white supremacist
rhetoric is gendered.
And by that I mean, that
the things that they say
about race often have
some other message
about masculinity or
femininity in them.
I was particularly
fascinated by the way
that they talked about white men.
And I'll say more about
that in one second.
The second argument I made,
which I think is relevant today,
is that white supremacist rhetoric
is similar to mainstream political
and popular culture rhetoric.
So looking at those extremist
publications, I compared them
to the mainstream rhetoric
at the time of politicians
like Pat Buchanan and Bill
Clinton, to be completely bipartisan
about it, and also looked
at popular culture themes.
And there was a lot of
resonance between the two.
So I argued that they
were similar in some ways.
And then about the gendered
argument, it sort of came together
with the argument that
they're similar
to the mainstream in
an image like this.
So not only did I look at the
text, I also looked at the images
and line drawings and these
whites supremacist publications.
This one is from Tom Metzger's
White Aryan Resistance Publication.
And what you see here is a
line drawing of a white man.
He's wearing a baseball cap,
I don't know that it's red.
But he has on a construction vest.
And in the background are bridges
and cities and an airplane.
The message here is that
white men built this nation
and white men are this nation.
And my argument about
the mainstream,
you can see in a more
recent example from --
this is the History Channel, right.
They're doing a series on
the Men who Built America.
The American economy was linked
by railroads, fueled by oil,
and built by steel, right.
The same kind of rhetoric.
And my argument about white
supremacy is that it erases
and ignores the labor of people
of color, of Native Americans
who were in this land before.
So that's the work
that I did early on.
Then the Internet happened.
Now, I know for those of
you sitting in this session,
you know that the Internet
happened well before 1997.
But it was really starting
to take off in higher ed,
and I started using the Internet
in my classes and teaching with it.
I also began wondering how was the
Internet changing white supremacy.
I kept following those same groups
that I had looked at and analyzed
in the printed publication,
and I wanted to know how it
was changing those groups.
So I started work on the second
book, called Cyber Racism,
and part of what I found
is that instead of having
to drive seven hours to the
Southern Poverty Law Center archive,
the white supremacist rhetoric
that I had studied before was
now much easier to access, right.
I could find it in my living
room and dial it up that way.
It was also global, so that
people were making connections
across the globe around
white supremacy.
And it was more participatory.
People were contributing
their own takes on it.
But the point is it made
my research much easier
and it also made it easier
for these groups to connect.
So this is one of the places that
I studied in the cyber racism book.
This is Stormfront, you
may have heard of it.
It's the longest running white
supremacist portal online.
And I spent lots of hours
there so you don't have to.
When I finished research
for the book in 2008,
they had about 129,000
registered users.
When I checked last
week, there at 325,683.
And that number only
goes up, or it has so far
since I've been researching it.
On the night President Obama was
elected in 2008, so many people went
to Stormfront that they
crashed the servers there.
So I was concerned about
the extremist groups,
but I equally I was
concerned about my students.
I was teaching at the time
in a suburban private
university on Long Island.
And I was concerned
about how they were going
to stumble upon white supremacist
rhetoric online just in their course
of doing research for their term
papers and that sort of thing.
So I want to tell this one
story about taking my students
on Long Island into a computer lab.
This is in the early '90s.
It was before Google even.
That'll tell you how
long ago it was.
And so we were using different
kinds of search engines: Yahoo,
AltaVista -- what's another one?
Anyway, lots of different
search engines
that have gone by the wayside now.
Two students come in
and one student typed.
The first thing that
that student typed
in was KKK.com into a search engine.
And the next student, another
student in that same class,
typed in Martin Luther
King into a search engine.
They both ended up at
white supremacist sites.
And I said, that's
really what I'm interested
in in this work is understanding
my students' search patterns
and how they might stumble upon
white supremacist rhetoric.
Now, this is one of the
sites, this is the site
that my student came upon.
And how I found it was through them.
This is what I refer to, it
appears to be a tribute to Dr. King,
but in fact, it's run by
Stormfront, that large portal
that I showed you just previously.
So this is what I came to
call a cloaked website.
Like the one that I started the
presentation with that was talking
about slavery, what both of
these sites and lots of others
that I could tell you
about later do is
that they intentionally
disguise authorship in order
to conceal a political
agenda, right.
In some ways these cloaked websites
were precursors to today's news.
Part of what makes them difficult
to decipher is it's not clear
who is publishing them and
what their point of view is.
So this was especially difficult
for my students in college classes,
even though we were talking about
some of these issues already,
they struggle to make sense of them.
So this is what I decided
to do in terms
of my research is I would ask
young people, actually younger
than college students -- so I
recruited participants who were 15
to 19 years old, all from New York,
all from fairly good high schools.
And ask them to try and make
sense of these search results.
Like if they searched for
information on Dr. King
and they came across this site,
how would they make sense of it.
And then, I also asked them
to evaluate pairs of websites.
So I would pair a cloaked site
with a legitimate civil
rights organization site.
So this is a pairing here of a
Martin Luther King cloak site
and then the site from the
King family and their archive
of King's papers and
that sort of thing.
And then the second pairing
I did was actually a Library
of Congress site.
I paired that cloaked site, the
American civil rights review
that has the slavery information
from WPA, with the Voices
of Civil Rights, which was created
and hosted here at the Library
of Congress, and asked young people,
so how would you make sense of this.
So what I found was interesting
in terms of their understanding
of this material and
how they made sense
of information from the archive.
The first thing, and this is the
bright spot and the encouraging part
of my talk, which is that
they were very savvy.
Even in a 2007/2008 when I was doing
this analysis, they were very savvy
about the way that
websites looked, right.
They picked up on graphic
user interface.
They picked up on colors that
were not good and on fonts
that were not clear or
didn't look sophisticated.
This one a young person said, this
site looks like someone, you know --
just an individual created it, it
doesn't look very professional.
So she said she wouldn't trust it,
wouldn't trust the
information there, right.
So the good news is that
they're very sophisticated
about the look of sites.
The bad news, as we know now,
is that all it takes really is
a much better graphic designer
to fool someone with information.
So the other thing that I asked them
about was the content of the site.
So beyond the look of the site,
how do you evaluate the content
that you're looking at there.
And this is a page further
into that one about slavery.
And what's interesting, what
I wanted to point out here is
that part of what this white
supremacist Joe Weltner had done was
to -- sorry, Frank Weltner.
What he had done was he had taken
this language of multiculturalism,
of forgotten black voices,
and then taken the WPA quotes
of formerly enslaved people --
who would say things like, yes,
we were allowed to grow
vegetables when we were enslaved .
And takes those out of
context and reframes them
in a white supremacist
context, right.
For some of the young
people I talked to,
this was very hard to make sense of.
And this is some of what they said.
One young person said, I mean --
looking at this site
I just showed you.
I mean, I don't think I
would disagree with it.
I'm sure there are some
slaves that were treated well,
so I can understand
their point of view.
There's always two
sides to everything.
Now, as an educator, this is a
little horrifying, and I'm sure some
of you share that as well.
One of the other participants
I talked to read this material
and said, I don't know about this
because I've read other things
about slavery, and I know that
that this isn't true, right.
So she was able through
a kind of, you know,
what I would call a burgeoning
critical race consciousness
to make sense of this
site through other things
that she had read outside
the context of that one site.
So in conclusion, I
just want to say this.
So my research really sits,
kind of by accident in a way,
on either side of the
Internet, right.
This analysis in the printed only
newsletters of white supremacists
and then in the Internet
era of their work.
And what I can tell you is that,
whether in a printed archive
at the Southern Poverty Law
Center, or in a digital archive
at the Library of Congress, the
goal of white supremacy is the same.
Both before and after the Internet.
And that is to roll back
hard-won social, legal,
political, and moral victories.
And what we know is that the
Internet and digital archives,
unfortunately, make
this even easier.
Thanks very much.
[applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.